I'd like to tell you a bit about my
latest Obsession which is the early days
of the Railway things were very exciting
so you have to imagine this is like
completely brand new they had no idea of
the best way to send trains around the
country at this point in time stage
coaches had been the normal form of
transport and with stage coaches they
had timetables but I mean they were
loose at best so posters would appear
saying what time a stagecoach would
leave and it would often appear with a
caveat like God willing and leaving at
12 p.m barring accidents I'm not
actually checking it's from genuine
posters by the way so when it first came
to trains they kind of had the same
attitude just you know Chuck a train
along the track and it'll be absolutely
fine timetables I mean these are
considered quite loose guides
so there was one guy particularly famous
he was known as the railway King he was
called George Hudson he was once uh
shown that actually his trains would
often run really late and so he counted
by saying that actually often they also
ran early so that on average his trains
ran on time
that's the kind of world we're in if a
train didn't turn up at the next station
they would often send a train out along
the same track in the opposite direction
to look for it I don't know about you
but I can definitely see a problem with
that and actually Brunel in particular
had a very relaxed attitude towards
safety so he was once asked what he
would do if he saw another train coming
towards him and he responded that he
would basically stoke the fires Go full
speed and just try and round them off
the tracks just a little bit of
background for you from the type of
situation we're in but then there were
some really quite major accidents once
passages started going along the railway
rather than just Freight there were some
quite major accidents
and people realized that it was really
important to work out a way to make sure
that there was only one train on a piece
of track at a time I'm going to struggle
to contain my excitement of this because
I think it's genuinely amazing but this
really incredible idea was had by a
French Railway worker called Charles
ibru this is 1847 and he decided that
maybe what we should do is use a very
particular type of graph I'm calling it
a train graph I'm not sure if that's the
official phrase but here is how the
train graph works so his graph manages
to simultaneously show all of the
Stations between Paris
and ruin so you have all of these
stations along here I'm not even going
to pretend that I know what they are do
you want to give me some comedically
French names Renault Eiffel Tower okay
okay you got the Eiffel Tower uh you got
Renault up here uh poincare I'm pretty
sure
our Lane Frost
Zinedine Zidane
look this is accurate uh you got Oola
there we go and baguette
it's getting increasingly
problematically so you've got all of
your stations the important thing about
this is the distance between the
stations on here represents the distance
along the track you're representing the
real Railway track on the paper but the
other dimension of course is time and
then along here let's say your train
starts at like 6 a.m and then let's go
through to like midnight so you've got a
one-dimensional map on one side and then
you've got the time of day along the
other now you can start adding trains on
this so let's say that you have got a
train that leaves Paris at 6am and gets
to ruin at I'm just going to assume this
is quite a slow train given the way that
I've heard you on just go with me okay
so you've got a train that leaves Paris
at 6am and let's say that it gets in to
ruin at let's say 3 P.M so now all you
have to do is draw a straight line
between the two right that's kind of
straightforward and nice and easy let's
imagine then that you have a train that
you want to leave Juan Kare and it
leaves one car at 6am and it gets in
let's say at 5 00 PM now that looks like
it'll be fine you could just draw that
line on the track except you would have
a massive problem if you did that
because where these lines cross on this
graph it also means that they cross in
real life it means that there is going
to be a point at about three o'clock in
the afternoon where these two trains are
going to have to cross over on the same
piece of track so basically that that
power strain is going to kind of go up
the back side of that one isn't it like
exactly we're gonna have a giant problem
you've got a really slow freight train
and then another fast one that wants to
come through I mean you just can't do it
so if you want if this train can't go uh
can't go any faster the only option that
you have is either to move this speed
train and change the time of that or
instead to just slide this train along
and have it so that it actually leaves
one Curry just after this Express train
has come through so have it so it does
something like this so now actually
that's fine that train fits all nicely
there's no problem there at all or the
other option is that you could change
the speed of this train so that you can
still have it leave at 6am but actually
try and give it some Gusto and just make
it go a little bit faster so that maybe
it arrives at 1pm so still not quite as
fast as the express train but just go
going a little bit faster those are your
options
a little bit later you could say at this
station here at Alan Frost Alan prast
you could have a sort of vertical line
so that at every point during the day
there was a place at which a train could
pull over and allow another train to
pass so that any Crossings along that
line of Alan prast are actually actually
fine it's not it's not a problem at all
in fact let's do that let's let's draw a
line so anything along this red line of
Alan Frost is absolutely fine so
anything that crosses there isn't going
to be a problem but you start populating
this graph with all of these trains
anything that needs to go from one place
to another this essentially allows you
to fix how fast trains can possibly be
because you know absolutely cold hard
fact you cannot have two lines crossing
on this graph unless they're at a
special station where you know there's a
place to pull over so if you've got this
really kind of well-populated graph
remember they're always going in this
direction because time always moves
forwards and in this particular example
they're always going from Paris to Rion
rather than and the other way around on
the line that we have but this is like a
way that you completely have your
constraints totally fixed now the thing
about this graph that I think is so
amazing invented in the 1840s still used
today so until very very recently if you
went into somewhere like
um National Rail you would find people
with uh with literally like this pieces
of paper and rulers working out exactly
how fast the train is faster Trains
being slightly steeper slower Trains
being a slightly shallower gradient and
they would literally be with a pencil
and paper trying to work out how to
timetable new trains and all of the
software now that has replaced the paper
still operates on exactly this principle
that the best possible way to create a
timetable for real life is to kind of
visualize it in this imaginary space of
distance and time in Singapore on the
MRT the Metro stations there there was
an issue a couple of years ago with a
rogue train so there was this this
problem on the track where lots of
trains were losing power they weren't
really sure what was going on and it
wasn't one train that seemed to have an
issue it wasn't like they could narrow
it down and say okay this is the train
that's that's the problem it was lots
and lots of different trains were having
issues and they worked out what the
problem was
only by using one of these train graphs
because
um when they plotted the entire day's
timetable on the train graph they could
see that actually one naughty train was
essentially emitting a signal and
causing knock-on effects in any train
that passed it so it would be as though
this train as it kind of goes along ends
up causing a problem in this train and
in this train and in this train anytime
it got within the vicinity of another
train at this naughty train the Rogue
train was causing an issue and it's only
by visualizing it using these graphs
that they spotted that was the problem
check out the links in the video
description for more of our videos with
Hannah we'll also have links down there
to the latest of Hannah's books podcast
work anything else that might be of
interest go and check out the video
description I always thought that those
were the couples who who would end up
being the most successful but the team
found that it's actually the exact
opposite that's true